we have major major news to discuss
today Prince Harry and Megan have
announced where they will be vacationing
at the end of the year no obviously not
don't worry this is still the David
Pakman show there's a ton to say about
the real news which is we had our first
full day of Donald Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings and on the one hand
there is a lot to say and then on the
other hand there there isn't that much
to say in a sense I'll explain what I
mean by that the high light or the low
light depending on your proclivity was
that Donald Trump had an absolute and
total breakdown on Twitter as basically
everything that has been asserted so far
about the Trump Ukraine Fiasco was
corroborated with some new allegations
and assertions made which we will get to
a little bit later on in the program a
Donald Trump spending the entirety of
the just hour after hour after hour
impeachment hearings I think running
about 6 hours in total tweeting Trump
tweeting a total of by my count 26 times
during the impeachment hearings clearly
panicked and clearly erratic and clearly
furious but at the same time clearly not
understanding the content of the
impeachment inquiry hearings which we
will also talk about because if I were
to top-level it for you if someone
watched nothing of the hearings
yesterday and I had seven seconds to
tell them what happened I would say
everything that has been asserted so far
was corroborated and even worse
allegations were made or even more
incriminating things were were said and
and that is of course what we gleaned
from the best recollection of the two
witnesses what we've heard so far from
the whistleblower and from Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh and from
Gordon Sunland and the whole host of
them was corroborated so let's refresh
and we'll get to Donald Trump's tweets
yesterday was day one of the Trump
impeachment inquiry hearings tomorrow
Friday will be day two during which we
will hear from Murray
Jovanovic yesterday we heard testimony
from William Taylor the former US
ambassador to Ukraine and George Kent
the
top envoy to Ukraine now the thing about
the hearings was that they were long and
they were slow and they were detailed
and they were by the standards of 2019
low attention span dopamine hit media
culture they were boring and they were
complicated everything that causes
Donald Trump and his followers to think
that nothing happened here it's a
nothing burger it was nonsense
it was old guys talking in circles about
nothing but if you paid attention you
would have noticed that the questions
from Democrats who were actually trying
to learn something were answered with
clear corroborations of the story as
it's been told thus far there was
context there was history there were all
of these things that don't make great
clips for five o'clock and 11 o'clock
news but the quid-pro-quo the
expectations from Trump of Ukraine the
military aid so on and so forth all
corroborated thanks to the questioning
of Democrats along with some
grandstanding as well I completely admit
now the Republican questions were almost
postmodern simply repeating vague
epistemological questions because they
could not actually put together a line
of questioning that pointed to anything
other than attempted bribery by Donald
Trump and the people around him can you
think of something and be wrong about
your opinion could you misinterpret the
intentions of someone else haven't
people been wrong before about what they
believed happened and as I tweeted
yesterday for a group that claims to be
against post-modernism and relativism so
ardently Republicans had nothing to go
to other than these hypotheticals about
how do we know what we know can we know
anything is anything really knowable is
true because they had nothing else to
understand Republican questions at
yesterday's impeachment hearings you
also had to understand a lot of viral
Facebook nonsense because a lot of the
lines of questioning from Republicans
that focused on imputing people's
character character assassination so on
and so forth if you
were not up to speed on popularly shared
fake news articles and Facebook memes
and conspiracy theories you wouldn't
even understand where it was Republicans
were trying to go with their questions
yesterday uh and because of this of
course that is the defense that they are
going with they try to remind they're
low information supporters that even
though the witnesses are being
completely consistent in their testimony
and their corroborating what's already
been alleged everyone might just be
misremembering or misinterpreting things
that is effectively the defense that
they tried to frame up it's not really a
defense but sadly Donald Trump fell for
it and that means Donald from followers
will fall for it and think that
yesterday was merely just hey this is
people saying things that could be wrong
and that's it so then we get to Donald
Trump's tweets just completely all over
the place and again how does a president
have this much time to tweet lots of
retweets of lunatic extremist content
for example a video of absolutely
bonkers Republican Jim Jordan asking
questions with some bogus talking points
from Republicans on the Oversight
Committee a retweet of a big sign
claiming that Adam shift learned the
identity of the whistleblower 93 days
ago which is not only untrue it's also
irrelevant but again we we have time
we'll get to that a little bit later
retweeting a video obviously from Fox
News show Fox & Friends where extremist
Republican Kevin McCarthy McCarthy calls
this entire impeachment hearing process
a sham what is Trump doing all day that
he sends out tweet after tweet after
tweet nearly 30 tweets during a six-hour
hearing and speaking of Fox News by the
way because Fox News was the subject
matter of a lot of Donald Trump's tweets
and retweets Fox News is now fully back
on the Trump bandwagon as far as
yesterday's coverage goes covering the
impeachment hearings by defending Trump
by gaslighting viewers with completely
bogus side by side biographical
information about Adam Schiff and
William Taylor and we'll talk about some
of those bogus misleading graphics that
Fox News put up a little bit later in
the show
but first we need to deal with a bigger
picture issue in general with these
hearings and the
amplification of media